hi in this video we are going to talk
about nucleotide excision repair system
which is one type of dna damage repair
cell uses nucleotide excision repair to
fix dna
regions which contains chemically
modified bases and often that leads to a
distortion in the
dna helix
so we are exposed to harmful radiation
such as uv all the time and it can lead
to damage in our dna let me tell you how
let's say there are two thymine bases
which are adjacent to each other and
this kind of uv radiation can lead to a
production of thymine thymine dimer
which is one kind of dna lesion
and this kind of dna lesion leads to a
distortion in the dna helix
and this distortion is detected by the
nucleotide excision repair system which
further recruits components such as uvr
a uvrb c and d to
repair this kind of distortion
now as the name suggests uvr a b and c
these kind of proteins
can help our body to recover from a
uv mediated dna damage
and in this video we are going to talk
more about these proteins this component
how exactly they function so stay tuned
till the end of this video
nucleotide excision repair system is
highly conserved throughout the species
from e coli to human you would get these
kind of repair system
for simplicity we are going to look at
the
e coli nucleotide excision repair system
and then we are going to delve into
details in human
nucleotide excision repair
so
this process begins by detection of a
distortion in the dna helix
and the key component that detects the
dna distortion is the uvr a proteins
now once it detects the distortion it
will recruit
uvrb protein into the site of this
lesion
and this
recruitment requires
hydrolysis of atp
because this is quite a energy expensive
process
after uvr b is recruited to the site of
the lesion there would be a bending of
this dna segment
after that
uvrc gets recruited to this site of
distortion
uvrc leads to a cleavage
at a particular portion which is
slightly away from the site of
this damage
then
uvr d
which is kind of like a helicase it
would be recruited to this site and it
would chop off this particular segment
of the dna
and ultimately there would be a gap
which is generated after this process
dna polymerase one
can ultimately
polymerize this three prime hydroxyl
group
and try to repair this graph
and the last
gap is actually repaired by a ligase
enzyme it is sealed by the ligase enzyme
and thereby that now the dna is repaired
and the thymine thymine
dimer formation is excluded and thereby
our repair system saves our dna every
day from these kind of damages
now let us look at this process in
eukaryotes especially
in human
obviously we can imagine
human is way more complicated than
e coli so this particular process would
involve many more proteins indeed this
process
involves about 25 to 30 proteins
but they have similarities
in terms of the mechanism
and there are they have counterparts
with e coli let's try to understand that
so the principle is similar the dna
distortion has to be detected by some
kind of detection mechanism and that is
xpc
by the way this xp stands for xenodharma
pigmentosum and we'll come to it in a
moment
so just like uvra xpc recognize the site
of distortion
then there is xpd and xpa
which kind of creates a bubble around
this site of distortion
and this bubble is held steady with the
help of rpa proteins which are kind of
single stand strand binding proteins
then away from this site of distortion
in the five prime end there would be a
exonu there would be a nucleus
recruitment which is ercc one xpf
this new this nuclease would cleave the
five prime site and the three prime site
is actually cleaved by xpg
so what we can understand
the overall mechanism is very similar
for example this each the this ercc one
xpf
and
xpg is kind of similar to uvrc protein
but here in human we can see there are
many more components
and that is why the process is bit more
complicated in human
but overall there is a similarity
between these two organisms that means
the recognition
the cleavage and then the repair
now let me tell you one human
disease is known as xenodharma
pigmentosum which is a very rare skin
disorder where a person is highly
sensitive to sunlight and especially the
uv radiation
and it can lead to cancer in these kind
of patients
and often it has been seen that the risk
genes are x p xpa xpc xpd
and all of these genes as i have
mentioned earlier are the component of
nucleotide excision repair system in
simple words in these patients the
nucleotide
repair system is messed up that is why
they are more susceptible to uv mediated
damages which can lead to skin cancers
now we understand that why nucleotide
excision repair is super important from
a clinical point of view
now let me tell you that apart from
being a dna repair system this
particular
repair system is also transcription
coupled
that means let's say a particular
transcription
process is going on and this rna
polymerase is moving in the gene body
transcribing the rna
but suddenly it experiences a thymine
time in dimer which has created a
distortion so obviously the rna
polymerase would be stalled
but luckily rna polymerase is associated
with
um
with this
particular
dna repair machinery that means it can
recruit one component of the rna
polymerase more specifically tf one
component with the rna polymerase
machinery tf2h
is involved in transcriptional coupled
repair it can recruit all the players of
nucleotide excision repair which would
repair this bulge
and ultimately
it would allow the trans the the rna
polymerase to move along and
transcribing this particular gene
so now we understand how nucleotide
excision repair is important so let us
get a quick summary
cells use nucleotide excision repair to
fix dna regions which has modified bases
or let's say a duct such as uh timing
time in dimer and this detection happens
via distortion in the normal shape of
the dna
and this is a local distortion nuclear
adaptation repair is very well conserved
from
prokaryotes to eukaryotes
mutation in xp family genes lead to
nuclear defect in the nucleotide
excision repair system which is the base
basis of
xenodharma pigment pigmentosum
and lastly we saw that nucleotide
excision repair is transcription coupled
and it also allows
a flexibility in terms of
gene transcription because gene
transcription can can't be stalled just
because there is a
lesion in the dna so it has to be
repaired rapidly and
it can lead to transcription in a
unpaused manner
so
overall the notes of this particular
topic will be available in my facebook
page whose link is provided in the
description
as usual don't forget to like share and
subscribe you can support my channel in
patreon i'm also present in unacademy
you can use my code ap 10 to get a 10
discount you can follow me on all the
social media i am present by this
particular name and all the links are
provided in the description so please
get connected and let me know in the
comment whether it is useful or not
thank you